yep um okay so we need two more wins and
uh
we're good
and what better way to get a win than to
play the old london system
which has served me so faithfully
for so long
three castles
where the what are the tricks here
usually c3 because that's the move i'm
gonna play
anyway basically once bishop d3
makes it seven right let me see at least
i haven't wasted time on
bishop g3 so should be able to
take and then knight e5
no can't be too bad
maybe he has mis mixed up his systems
here a bit
okay let's go f4
and uh let's just
let's just play for an attack we don't
want to trade those bishops
i'm claiming that my bishop is better
than his
even though his prevents me from
castling at the moment
and i understand that this is a highly
controversial claim
but i am prepared to
defend my my view as steinis would have
i'm prepared to defend it over the next
the next few minutes
so i can go queen of three next but
like leg would say i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna give you any [ __ ] figures here
i'm just gonna show my true intentions
at
once and go g4
and maybe after knight e7 i will slow
down
slightly and consider a move like queen
of three
so maybe i was bluffing maybe i wasn't
that
aggressively inclined
let's see
this is interesting he is allowing
he is allowing g5
and then queen h5
okay let me bring the rook instead then
keep him guessing ever so slightly
maybe you could have gone cd4 ed4 knight
d4 there
and just really really go for it you
know
queen before coming next it would might
have been
a tad unpleasant to to meet
in a practical game so now i'm
i'm now i am getting a little bit
worried
if i go if i go g5 here
well first of all there's 97.
queen f3 there is
cd4 and then
so maybe i should go knight df3
which is logical the reason i didn't
want to do that before and the reason it
didn't occur to me immediately
is that i don't want to allow his knight
to go to
to e4 but now that his knight has gone
gone away from f6 it feels a bit more
feasible he can go f6 i think i will
reply
by taking either knight
haven't decided which one yet probably
the one
probably the one on c6 i think
yeah i think the one on c6 and then i
will go g5
i can't do anything violent i think so
yeah i go take the one on c6 then i'll
go g5
f5 so he does close up close up the
position
yeah it's not so easy to do a whole lot
now
i probably either misplayed it or
there wasn't so much to begin with here
okay that's a good move probably should
have taken care of it
earlier um
not loving the development in this game
but i i feel like i should still be
relatively safe here okay we go queen d2
i'm not so sure actually that in general
opening up the game on the queen side is
good for him
when i may have a weak king long term
but
on the other hand um
these pieces are are not that
impressively placed right now bishop b5
is a good move though
now i do get ropes to c1
and uh we gotta we got a
typical stonewall structure which should
be
should be favorable to me
bishop a4
i'm not sure i want that okay well let's
just go back
you should play four that was b4 and b5
and then b4 i thought maybe then i could
go bishop a4 later on but
i'm not sure that's that was really
favorable okay so he decides
to exchange after all i think he's gonna
take with the queen
not to allow me to exchange any more uh
major pieces okay let me go a3
the idea is to go bishop a4 and then to
provoke b5 but not to allow
um not to allow
um
okay i gotta speed up sorry not too loud
before
um gotta speed up
whenever he exchanges i'm not worried
about that
um yeah he moves the knights along
i think i'm just gonna go a5 try and get
rid of the queen size
and then i have a space advantage and i
have a better bishop so
it's not like it's uh it's a dead draw
by any means here
but this one i don't like this one i
don't like at all
i get rookie 8 no oh he does a g6
okay maybe it's not a disaster
you can go bishop a4
oh that's really nice yeah that's really
nice threatening
i was threatening um 97 and
when he moves to kenya bishop c6 and now
he's just
utterly stalemated over there
okay so now we're just bringing the king
into the game i don't think he can
he can save it
yeah yeah it does have knight d7 but
i just take it and then i go knight c5
the bishop is actually completely out of
play on
uh on e4
yeah we give a check
97
with this i am conceding just a little
bit of control over the position but
it doesn't matter as this guy is just
running
queen and then rook h7 and that's game
over
okay four and a half
so we need one more